the Baldwin estate until today until
this film has not allowed an
english-language
adaptation of a Baldwin novel yet with
great power comes great responsibility
what was your pitch to the estate why
and why was this novel so important to
you my pitch was a very naive pitch I
wrote the script in the summer of 2013
on the same writing trip that I thought
I wrote the screenplay for moonlight and
at that time I just wanted to write and
so I didn't have the the rights to the
novel so I came back from Europe with
the adaptation the screenplay and I just
sent it to the estate and I think what
worked about that was I didn't go in
going hey this is what I'm going to do
this is what I plan to do it was this is
literally what I plan to do all my cards
on the table and it began a four year
process of the estate becoming familiar
with me me becoming familiar with the
estate and eventually they granted us
the rights to the source material from
your very earliest conversation with
Nick Patel who we should say did the
music for moonlight where did you start
how did the book suggest its own
soundtrack and where did you guys work
backward from the songs that you place
in the story that's kind of prompts in
the film yeah I mean the songs mentioned
in the book were very expensive so
they're not in the film but uh but for
me even reading the book for the first
time writing the script talking to James
about it because James and I always
connect on visual ideas very early in
the process even we were making
moonlight we were already having visual
discussions about Beale Street that
seemed to reveal itself as jazz and so
when Nick and I connected it was about
jazz James Baldwin was a jazz man his
father was a jazz man and I felt like
the language that blends both romance
and despair to me as the language of
jazz and so we started out as a
direction
I'm not a destination but working with
primarily brass saxophone trumpets
flugelhorn and things like that and then
Nick just took it and yeah no absolutely
it was that was the first conversations
I think we had where Barry said that he
was hearing
horns he was hearing brass and one of
the things that I love and find so
inspiring about working with Barry is
that these things are just starting
points for us I think both of us are so
aware that the filmmaking process but in
particular I think you know music is
such an abstract and sort of amorphous
entity and it's kind of a mystery I
think a lot of the ways that film and
music connect and what that what is the
right way to do that what is the right
feeling so we started with brass and
horns but then I wrote some pieces with
you know barrows much thing I was
working with flugelhorns and trumpets
and cornets Ahrens and then when I
played them for Barry and we tried them
against some of the early sequences of
the cut it felt like something was
missing and we discovered that we were
missing strings and for us the strings
coupled with the brass but really the
strings became I think the feeling of
love that's in the film that takes so
many different shapes James I want to
ask you about how that same idea kind of
lend itself to a visual language for the
film we have these really difficult
photographs some taken by a great
photographers like Danny Lyon of what's
happening in the world at the time does
that suggest to you something to work
again something to incorporate what were
the earliest conversations about how you
would shoot especially these two
characters in this film yeah I mean well
it's funny hearing you guys talk about
your process it just sounds so identical
- very nice as well it's this sort of
like long conversations that I don't
remember the first conversation we had
about Beale Street for example I don't
know the first most about moonlight it
because of our friendships going back so
long these things germinate for years
and years and years and so I think when
it comes time to choose like you know go
back to your question the shooting
format for example they'll s6 Lux at 65
is what we shot the film on why we chose
that it's hard to pin down but I think
once we saw you know faces which is what
this film is about that's these two
people in love and looking back each
other through the glass or just looking
at each other across a table having
dinner it just felt like these large
format concepts just suited the
emotional loving impact that we were
trying to present the story up on so but
yeah I mean love was definitely a
centerpiece I mean I think making that
play off of the
socio-political issues I think made both
things stronger if we could present this
couple in love and have the our audience
connect on that level we could
understand the empathy it takes to
engage with other parts of the story
Carol I wanna ask you about a couple of
choices you make but I want to start
with Alice Hunt and about how you
costumed her because her wardrobe is so
telling I think in terms of who she is
who she says she is and how she's almost
kind of fighting against herself in the
clothes that she's wearing she's not a
very pleasant person she's a bit
sanctimonious so we sort of went for the
most hypocritical color we could and a
sunny sort of optimistic yellow so that
was that was I mean of how she holds
herself and then what about Tish and
Fani what were you looking for they come
from different means so they're
obviously gonna have different wardrobes
but what are the things that were
important to illustrate and your choices
for that was funny it was all about
found objects about found things you
know it's it's his clothes come from the
sixties come from he's found these
pieces he's an artist he's not got you
know he's not of money and so I do think
that there is a sort of sensibility
there but you know that red and black
you know jump with lumberjack jacket
which Baldwin writes about you know it's
from the 40s or the 50s I mean Ronnie's
just found that you know wearing it now
you know he sort of pieces these things
together Tish I like to think of you
know her colors and in their flashback
scenes are very optimistic and they're
about purity then it gets a little
darker a little bit you know in our
present day sort of story and a little
more mature if you will most definitely
I always kind of wanted to have an arc
of mature
with her.she I think it was about that's
it it's an old against the the what
she's facing now the purity the
present-day there are scenes in prison
that probably are shot over the couple
of days that span not only months but
incredibly different circumstances in
your character's life what kind of work
did you do with Barry to be able to do
that those scenes back-to-back where so
much is happening to your character and
it could be morning you're in pretty
good shape and afternoon something
horrible has afflicted you that day yeah
luckily enough we we had the prison
stuff all sort of in the same week so
yes Barry was nice enough to make sure
that happened but yeah I mean you know
it's a um I guess you know you know the
whole character arc of funny you sort of
see him at as high as high as his most
joyous moments when he's you know when
he's in in front of his love when
they're making love when when they're
receiving their their first home
together when he's finding out that this
baby's about to come into the world but
then also you have to go into these sort
of dark times where you know he sees
obviously he's been institutionalized
you know in a place where you know these
walls are meant to break down these
young men to literally break their
spirits physically mentally all that so
you know to have to have to knowingly
know what that's like to go through that
and then to have to you know exude this
this strength through a glass to my wife
into my unborn child this light that's
about to come into the world and to have
to I guess manage that sense of
vulnerability and and understanding what
it is that she's going through and and
giving her that much you know it's so
much tougher through through the glass
but you know in terms of sort of just
that whole arc you know I gotta give
a lot of credit to to to Kiki you know
for me she really brought a lot that
that you know I think Fani was forced to
lean on her a lot in those scenes lean
on her strength and and and to you know
to feel strong in that I think that you
know we had wonderful hair and makeup
departments that you know helped with
sort of fawni's Aging in prison which
was you know as for me as an actor it's
it's it's um you know visually to have
to live with myself like that and look
at myself like that it does it does so
much it really it puts you in a place
then you know for me I based this
character off a young man by the name of
kalief Browder who in in New York in
2010 16 year old boy who was charged
with petty theft of a backpack a crime
that he didn't commit and he was sent to
Rikers Island and and spent three years
on Rikers Island two and a half and
solitary confinement as a 16 year old
boy awaiting trial never trial yeah
never tried and and for me you know to
have to look at his face and just you
know what you would never see what it is
that he had to exactly go through and
those in those walls but to have to see
him talk about it I mean it's the
scariest thing in the world and it's the
scariest thing in the world because you
realize that this is just one of a
million people who are going through the
exact same thing who you will never see
a documentary about you will never see a
film about and and and for me that's why
this this film means so much is is
you're able to bring a level of humanity
to these characters who often you know
get written off as as a statistic you
know one in three black men are gonna be
incarcerated by the time they're 40
years old and you don't really think
about the fact that these people are
human beings and they and they love and
they have families who love them back
and and you know that's constantly being
threatened by a system that that's
supposed to be you know put in place to
protect you but you know it's it's
failing you time and time again so
you know for me all that goes into into
what I sort of wanted to bring to those
prison moments is to give a voice to the
voiceless keiki I'm gonna ask you as the
newbie here about your first
conversations with Barry and about how
you found your way into Tisch what were
the most important conversations that
you had with Barry and was there a path
that you found to understanding her and
how she didn't give up and how she hung
in there and her resilience and her love
for this man even against these really
trying circumstances I mean I think
overall an important you know
conversation with Barry was just him
reminding me to trust myself and to
trust why you know he put me in the role
that you know he saw something in me
that I would be able to bring you know
Tisha's story to you know life and and
bring that truth to it and so I feel
like that was the main thing that we you
know had to discuss and you know he just
had such a open ear to hear you know
what I was discovering as you know
directors fo have so much to pay
attention to you know all of these
moving parts as they're putting this
entire film together but me the actor I
am invested in this one role and so it's
just all that I think about it is
changing how I am speaking and walking
and living and and so he was always
interested to hear you know about that
and so it was always just very open
dialogue about you know how was Tisch
you know really feeling and trying to
you know break out of me
and so I was very thankful you know just
to be able to have those conversations
and you know then to just feel so
supported you know as the newcomer oh
you know having such a big
responsibility but having the least
experience on a film set and just
feeling so wrapped up by everyone you
know there was a part of this film like
just how you see in the movie all of
these characters coming around Tisch
that's how all these people that we're a
part of this film came around me which
is I think added to you know making that
sense of family and you know
all of that truth made it even more real
but then in terms of you know my own
preparation lucky for me the book is
written from my character's perspective
so I had a lot to work with but know
there's so much in the book about what
Tish is feeling and thinking and how
she's responding to all these new
experiences they bury you know had to
say of course all of this camp make it
into the screenplay but it had to make
it into our performances so I was very
aware of that and so you know while
filming I read the book multiple times I
had it with me every day on set you know
referencing get like oh if we're working
on this scene fighting it in the book
and seeing you know what information
maybe was available in the book that
didn't make it you know into the script
but like Barry said still had to make it
into my performance but yeah I don't
know just I don't know folk so so
supported Baldwin wrote this book in the
late sixties through 73 is published in
1974 in many ways horribly James Baldwin
saw a lot of things that were coming a
lot of things that weren't gonna change
what do you think this story means to
today's audience and is it in some ways
heartbreaking that this is not some sort
of time capsule that this story is with
us as much as it is today as it was 40
years ago yeah I think it's an
indictment in a certain way of just a
passivity on all our parts I think that
there's been so much progress that's
been made both outside our industry in
the country at large within our industry
and yet we see especially given what's
happened in the last 18 months in our
own industry how much more progress
there remains to be made we decided to
allow the novel to remain set or the
film to remain set in the period it was
written just to pay proof to power that
these problems have been allowed to
persist and so I think it says that
there's just so much more progress that
data that needs to be made and for me to
be brutally honest I think it shows that
we have to find a way you know dave
franco appears as this jewish landlord
this character levy who's written in the
book and i was trying to find a way how
what's the genuine connection between
these two people why is he treating them
treating somebody to negro so nice like
as Stefan's character says
and it's just a Tupac jumps in my head
you know we all came from a woman we all
have mothers and to me everything's
about nature versus nurture and with
this film I think what mr. Baldwin was
saying just to find a way to love each
other build families be a part of a
collective community and so I think we
have to find a way to give people the
freedom the space the tools to nurture
and be nurtured I think if you watch
this film and you leave with anything
that's what I hope I think that's what
mr. Baldwin hoped it's why we wanted to
confirm the families intact at the end
of the film and I think for all of us up
here you know just breathing life into
this thing that was the whole damn point
Barry Nick James Caroline Stefan Kiki
thank you so much for bringing us your
film